this is a production of Cornell
University
okay so I think after long day now it's
it's time for me I guess to entertain
you for the next hour or so
and try to keep you awake and and what I
thought what I should do is share and
discuss with you our more recent work on
microbial association with healthy
plants and also proposed functions of
these microbes now since this is very
much a an emerging research field I
thought you know will be a proper to
give a brief introduction and so
personally I believe that really one of
the more profound discoveries in
molecular plant microbe interactions
during the last decade has been the
observation that healthy asymptomatic
plants in nature live in association
with a rich diversity of microorganisms
and in simple terms the some of the
microorganisms that live in association
that colonize a healthy asymptomatic
plants that's what called the plant
microbiota and it's important that
really for Association of healthy plants
with microbes that we see association
with different microbial classes so we
see for example association with
bacteria we have associated with
protests and we have also associations
with fungi and the microbes that live in
association with above-ground plants
that's often called the Phyllis fear and
the microbes that live in association
with low groan parts particularly the
root this is called the rhizosphere now
what I thought would be useful to
structure my presentation today what
I'll do is in the first part of my
lecture I will tell you what we've
learned about the bacterial plant
microbiota and then during the last
maybe 10 15 minutes I'll tell you some
recent findings of association between
healthy plants and Root associated fungi
I thought this might be interesting so
let's get started with a particular mood
micro bata and it's I think it's now
widely accepted that essentially all
flowering plants in nature are densely
colonized by by bacteria healthy
asymptomatic plants and literally
millions of bacteria colonized leaf
surface and the interior and it's very
similar to the roots which we find
zillions of bacteria that colonized the
root surface and also the root interior
what is slightly more controversial is
the source of inoculum of these leaf
associated bacteria because leaves a you
know they thrive in a in a natural open
environment and and and it's very clear
that there are multiple sources for
these leaf associated microbes but this
is quite different from the root from
the root microbe or tides it's now also
I think widely accepted that bacteria
that live in unplanted soil that those
bacteria defines the virtual start
inoculum for the formation of the root
microbe order and that has some
experimental advantages that I will
explain to you later during my
presentation so what I proposed
microvolt of functions for the plant
house there are a number of them and
these include nutrient mobilization
they're certainly strong evidence that
many root Associated bacteria help
plants to mobilize nutrients for plant
growth so plant growth promotion is has
been repeatedly reported there's
evidence for in the indirect pathogen
protection and I will report on that as
well a Barratt expressed tolerance and
increased fitness so it's almost too
good to believe and one has to be really
skeptical because many of these claims
are anecdotal and importantly many of
these claims are based on mono
associations so one microbiota member
plus one host under laboratory
conditions but the community context is
frequently missing so one needs to
really take these claims with a grain of
salt so these are our long-term
questions that we would like to address
for our work how can healthy plants
establish intimate association
to microbial communities how can plants
discriminate between beneficial and
pathogenic microbes I think this not
understood and and and lastly how do
plant associated microbial communities
promote plant health so this is really
what guides our research activities now
let's have a closer look into the root
Associated bacteria it's known actually
since more than hundred years that roots
growing in natural soil live an intimate
association with a diverse range of soil
borne bacteria and I think there's some
evidence now that it's really organic
compounds that are actively exuded by
roots into soil that those serve as
chemical cues and attract soil borne
bacteria many of these bacteria then
become enriched on the root surface and
some of them also make it inside so they
are bacterial root endophytes
now there are two numbers that I would
like you to keep in mind and the first
number is really that soil so unplanted
soil is an incredibly rich compartment
on this globe for bacteria and one gram
of soil contains between ten to the
seven to ten to the nine bacteria so
this is very important so essentially
roots are growing in a virtual broth
this is it's it's really a remarkable
observation the second important number
is that about 10 to 20 percent of carbon
dioxide atmospheric carbon dioxide that
is fixed via the Calvin Benson cycle in
green leaves is it is extruded as
organic carbon by roots into soils so
there's substantial organic carbon
sequestration by plants into soil and
you ask oh why why do plants invest so
much energy into soil
now conceptually I think the root is
analogous to the digestive tract of
vertebrates and you may ask why and I
think the arguments for this is both
organs the digestive tract as well as
roots are organs that are dedicated for
nutrient mobilization and nutrient
uptake
the difference is between the two system
this is a closed system this is an open
system and essentially you can
at a root you know as a digestive tract
where the inside is turned out and I
will come back to that in a minute so
then I thought it might be useful if
this works to briefly explain to you how
do we measure these route associated
virtual communities and this in a
cartoon explains the fractionation of
the Arab lobstah to dissociate virtual
microbiota which is now more or less a
standard protocol so what we do is we
grow our Arab adopters plants in natural
soil but in otherwise controlled
environmental conditions in the
greenhouse we grow them to bolting stage
then we harvest about three say three
centimeter long segments of arid OPS's
roots we wash the roots and collect the
soil particles that physically adhere to
the root surface and this is then what
we call the rhizosphere compartment in
subsequent to the washing we apply a
sonication step to deplete remaining
epiphytic bacteria from that root
surface and then we end up with these
washed and so located roots we
homogenize the roots to release bacteria
that thrive inside roots and this is
then what we call the root compartment
and then in a subsequent step we compare
the bacterial communities in the root
compartment with the bacterial
communities in the rhizosphere
compartment and as a control the vacuole
community is present in unplanted
natural soil it's very simple so how do
you molecularly characterize these
virtual communities we and essentially
most other groups in microbial ecology
use the bacterial 16s RNA gene it's
really the most widely used DNA sequence
for taxonomic assignments of the
currency it's technically a relatively
simple experiment you just use various
PCR primer combinations to amplify
segments of this particular 16s
ribosomal RNA genes and then the PCR
amplitudes are subjected to parallel
eliminar sequencing so that's you know
it's it's relatively standard what
becomes important is the computational
or the the bioinformatics processing of
these 16s sequences and so for this we
developed a customized pipeline we use
at least 10,000
high-quality reads per sample then the
first step there's a read alignment and
this is perhaps the most critical step
which is called complete linkage
clustering where all of the 16s RNA
sequences that share greater than 97%
identity are used for the definition of
a strange term which is called an
operational taxonomic unit so the tool
otu and to give you an idea of the
taxonomic of the resolution power of
these OT use this is roughly between the
bottle generous and the bacterial
species so it's very important to keep
in mind this technology fails to
discriminate between different strains
of one in the same species but it can
resolve in the best cases different
bacterial species and then you get two
types of information if you examine a
compartment you can define the number of
different Oh to use and you also obtain
the relative abundance you know which
one is abundant which one is a rare one
and those two informations are then used
for multivariate statistic analysis so
why don't we have a look into our early
work that was published now some time
ago where our goal was to characterize
the structure of the Arab adopts its
route MicroBot and for this purpose
we've grown our plants in natural soils
but under controlled environmental
conditions and then we've compared the
route associated bacteria with the
vacuole communities in the rhizosphere
compartment and in the unplanted soil
and this is typically how we visualize
these results it's a ternary plot and I
need to explain to you how to read these
these plots each dot represents and
vacuole owed to you as been defined by
its 16s sequence tag and the size
indicates the relative abundance so
let's say large dot represents abundant
bacteria small dots low abundance
picture a more important is the position
within this triangle because of the
position of a particular material ODU's
indicates the relative abundance of a
bacterium in these three compartments
and so what I've color-coded here
those bacteria
become enriched in Arabic OPS's roots
relative to unplanted soil and the
rhizosphere and what when you do the
taxonomic assignments of these root
enriched bacteria root enriched ODU's
they essentially define three bacterial
phyla they correspond to three virtual
phyla which are called actinobacteria
proto bacteria and bacteria data's so
relatively at this high taxonomic rank
you know a relatively simple taxonomic
structure the major take-home message
from independent experiments carried out
by debatable gorillas in our lab in
Cologne and by Jeff Daniels lab by
direct link back in the u.s. really
using soils from from two different
continents in Europe and us is that soil
type is the main determinant of root
microbiota composition host genotype
contributes limited variation relatively
simple take-home message so since that
time when we examined really the
structure of the arab drops issued much
of water and also some arab adopts us
relatives there were a number of
additional studies now published these
include various crop plants bali maize
grapevine and so on and quite recently
we've done a meta study we simply wanted
to know how similar or dissimilar is the
root Associated microbiota in all of
these different plant species right that
spend about 150 million years of
evolution and the result is actually
shown in this projection where each of
the dot represents a sample and the
proximity of the dots represents the
taxonomic similarity of the of the root
microvolt are and what you can see is
that essentially the taxonomic structure
of the root microbiota from these
different plant species is very similar
to each other but when we compare the
taxonomic structure of the root
associated that your microbots would
bethe gut with the human gut microbiota
it's it's there's essentially no overlap
so although as you recall both the
vertebrate gut and the root if you like
physiologically equivalent organs but
you know it's very clear the bacteria
that populate our digestive
like all of any other that where they're
totally different so the the major
lesson from this is there's a conserved
taxonomic structure of the bacterial
microrobots at final rank
proteobacteria Actinobacteria back to
the data same chemicals so it's it's a
highly conserved plant right now about
two years ago we we weren't entirely
satisfied with the type of work that we
were doing and we felt you know we were
really reaching is silly and essentially
what we were doing is we were we're
doing case control studies or time
series studies we applied the 16s RNA
gene community profiling that I've
explained to you we've applied
meta-genome sequencing and then we
inferred from these results hypotheses
that are based on statistics on advanced
statistics but if you really look
closely in our publications these are
correlations between multiple variables
and because I'm trained as a geneticist
I'm somewhat I'm not satisfied if you
end up with qualitative observations so
we felt that there might be an
opportunity on the long run to develop a
new branch of plant microbiota research
and this branch might involve really
systemic cultivation of the bacterial
plant microbe odor so high-throughput
virtual cultivation and then if this
were successful then we could design
synthetic bacterial communities that we
call Syncom and then we could add them
to germ-free plants and then we could
test the hypothesis you know from these
experiments and make scientific
conclusions that are based on causation
so that was the idea but a potential
caveat is that when we were talking with
our colleagues from environmental
microbiology that they told us well
whatever environmental sample you take
if you want to cultivate the bacteria
you can only cultivate barely 1% of them
so if that were true then of course you
could say well it's this entire approach
realistic right but there were reasons
why we were skeptical with the claims of
the environmental by microbiologist and
we there for about two or two-and-a-half
years ago we started to establish a
reference culture collection of the arab
adopts issued microbiota in this work
now impressive British weekly so I this
involves initially we collect roots
again from plants grown in natural soil
we wash them with Majin eyes roots and
they're very simple we just played the
root homogenates on agar plates or on 96
microtiter plates with liquid media and
as you can see by these two methods
we've now been able to isolate more than
5000 root derived bacterial colonies and
then we determined just by sequencing
the 16s RNA gene sequences from all of
these 5,800 virtual colonies and this is
why we call our culture collection
sequence index rise of virtual libraries
that are stored at minus 80 degrees and
can be used then for subsequent
experimentation so this is again to
remind you that our root culture
collection these 5,800 bacteria that
they are isolated from Arab topsis
plants growing in Cologne soil and in
parallel with our collaborator julia for
hold at the eth zurich we've also
isolated leaf associated bacteria of
arab topsis about three and a half
thousand and keep in mind that these
leaves were harvested from paradoxus
populations growing either surrounding
torij or in the vicinity of tubing so at
a geographic distance so then in the
next step this is really the most
critical one because what we needed what
we had to do is to cross-reference our
culture independent humidity data this
is the 16s community profiling where the
culture dependent approaches to really
estimate you know what fraction of the
root microbiota can we actually recover
as pure bacterial isolates and that's
shown on this slide where the inner
circle all of these small dots they
represent bacterial ODU root Associated
Pattillo to use from : Grohl Cologne
soil grown plants that we can resolve by
the 16s community profiling and in the
outer ring these
black squares they indicate hits in our
culture collection from these 5800
culture collection and the same is shown
here for the leaf derived patrol culture
collection so in total we've now
recovered more than 60% of the route and
the leaf associated bacteria so this is
clearly not a perfect culture collection
we still have some gaps but it's
certainly way more than the 1% that the
microbial ecologist wanted us to to
believe so the next question then was so
from from these thousands of thousands
of root and leaf associated bacteria
we've we've characterized really an
assemble the core collection that is
maximized for phylogenetic diversity and
that's shown by this phylogenetic trees
in the center of these slides and and
this represents the color code is really
according to bacterial phylum resolution
so you see actinobacteria bacteria Phil
Mickelson and proto bacteria but then
what we wanted to compare these two
culture collections and we wanted to
know how similar or different this
similar are the bacteria that associate
with healthy roots and leaves of arid
oxygen and that is shown in the most in
the outermost ring by these green arrow
heads or by the brown arrow heads
because this denotes a strain from our
culture collection from leaves that
shares greater than 97 percent identical
16s sequences so is essentially it's the
same species and we were quite surprised
to learn that 40 to 50 percent of the
root and leave drag the tool isolates
share greater than 97 so essentially are
the same sequences and in the same
bacterial species and we think this is
notable because recall our route and
leaf derived culture collections were
generated from plant material of
populations that are geographically
widely separated 500 kilometers apart so
that's something to keep in mind for
later on so then in the next step we
thought it would be useful to determine
whole genomes of all of our root and
leaf associate bacteria and we generated
whole genome
and also annotated the genomes of 432
micro volatile members and then inferred
a whole genome phylogenetic tree which
is shown here which is largely congruent
with a phylogenetic tree that is purely
based on the bacterial 16s ribosomal RNA
gene but this is mainly you know
archival but I think that genome
sequences are of course a very powerful
resource and one thing that we were of
course interested in having now access
to these whole genome sequences is to
study genome-wide functional diversity
between microbiota members of the root
and the leaf microbiota and what we use
for these experiments were really can't
annotated genes or CAG annotated
pathways and then simply compare how
similar or dissimilar those genes in in
these different genomes and what is
shown in these projections is each dot
represents a bacterial genomes and I've
color-coded the dots such that the rod
red dots represent root derived bacteria
and the green dots represent leaf
derived bacteria and again proximity is
a measure of functional similarity or
functional overlap and what we noted is
that we can clearly resolve different
clusters functional clusters functional
capabilities of these bacteria in our
culture collections but the functional
clusters they mainly correspond to
virtual fallujah not two-bit you'll
follow Janee so that there's a strong
phylogenetic signal but as you will see
in most of these clusters we find both
route associated and leaf associated
members so there must be a strong
functional overlap of members from the
root and the leaf microbiota and there's
actually only very few classes where you
can see a separation so at this level we
observed only weak signatures for niche
niche specialization at the whole genome
level and then Rubin Garrido he decided
to take this analysis one step further
and to look really for differential
enrichment of functions at individual
functional categories and this for
example involves carbohydrate metabolism
membrane transport so these are
high-level functions and what is shown
here this is a heat map and the relative
proportion of the genes that are
annotated to these high-level biological
functions and in the upper part Rubin
calculated for differential enrichments
between the root and the leaf microbiota
members and what he noted was there were
two functional categories carbohydrate
metabolism and I think xenobiotics bio
degradation and metabolism where we see
a highly significant difference between
the root and the leaf microbiota members
so at this level we see clear evidence
for niche specialization at individual
at least at two individual functional
categories and again you know this might
become important later on so now I would
like to come back and end to this scheme
and I hope I've convinced you that we
have a decent culture collection from
the root and the leaf microbiota we have
the whole genomes and we thought now we
under position that we can use this
culture collection and design synthetic
virtual communities add them to
germ-free plants event test but
particular hypothesis so this is what we
call microbiota reconstitution
experiments in the lab so for this
purpose I need to introduce to you Kell
sign clay which is an inert matrix for
colonization of germ-free arid OPS's
plants will define virtual communities
it's very simple you use this stee-rike
assigned clay and then you are inoculate
the curds and clay with defined inputs
and comps simultaneously with the sewing
of surface sterilized Arab lobster seeds
and then you you close the container you
grow the plants together with the
microbes in a closed container it's a
magenta box it's a very simple
experimental system was actually
originally developed this system by in
in the Lotus japonicus community by n
Stuart in Denmark and then after seven
weeks you determine outputs and combs of
calcium clay without host roots and then
you determine the output syndromes in
the roots and leaves using 16s community
profiling so I need to familiarize you
how to read
these data we typically display them by
heat maps and that's shown here this is
an experiment where we've added a root
derived 188 members income so from our
culture collection these are all route
arrived to clearing and this is the
input Syncom and the numbers indicate
biological replicates so each row
indicates a virtual replicate in each
line represents either a single material
strain or group of virtual strains and
the color code indicates the relative
abundance color code is relative
abundance we try for the for the input
community inoculate the bacteria to
one-to-one ratio so when after seven
weeks if we look at the route output
community you can see there's a marked
community shift so this community shift
can either be dependent on the host but
it can also be host independent and to
discriminate between those two
possibilities we also incubated the
input community for seven weeks just a
nun planted clay in the absence of those
and you see also a mark community shift
but if you then compare the output
community and unplanted play in roots
then you will note numerous changes for
example the relative abundance of this
victim increases this one barely grows
in unplanted play but in the presence of
the root is really dramatically enriched
this bacterium which is dominant in the
absence of the host becomes depleted
from root so you see really significant
changes but the surprise came when we
also analyzed leaves from these bacteria
so seven weeks later because we noted
that now many of the root derived
bacteria can also colonize a bit of
sleep so there's an ectopic localization
they make topic colonization of these
root Drive bacteria that was somewhat
surprising now the nice thing about this
experimental system it's quite flexible
so you can grow those Arab adopts as
plants for three weeks then you can open
the magenta boxes and you can spray them
with a leaf derived bacteria and then
you incubate them going to bait them for
another week and then do community
profiling after seven weeks and I think
this slide shows the result again this
is a highly complex community 226 men
this is the input communities now we
have only lived right back here this is
why the root ones are negative or black
and expectedly and we were quite pleased
about this most of these leaf drive
bacteria can abundantly colonize leaves
that's not so surprising but the
surprise again is if you now look at the
roots then you see the substantial
proportional subset of the leaf derived
bacteria can ectopic Lee also colonize
roots so bacteria from roots go up to
leaves and bacteria from leaves go down
to loops of course we have to quantify
these results this is where we use a bit
more quantitative analysis of these
community profiles
these are principal component analysis
of bread Kurtis dissimilarity matrix is
in principal and each of these or in
simple terms each of these dots
represents the community from a single
magenta box with four plants and what
I've color-coded here this is the input
community where we added the root Drive
bacteria to the calcite clay and these
are the output communities output
communities in the absence of the host
this is the root Associated output
community and the leaf associated output
community is very clear that the root
and the leaf output communities are
different and they're also different
from the output communities in the
absence of the host so this is the host
independent community shift and this is
the host
dependent community shift and this was
the second experiment that I explained
to you where we spray oculi the leaf
draft bacteria two leaves and this is
the input community output community on
the leaves and output from the act of
the colonization on roots so take-home
message from these experiments root and
leave drafts and crumbs colonize cognate
host organs but they are also capable of
ectopic leaf and root colonization
that's something that was rather
unexpected
so summarize this part of my
presentation we interpret these data
such that the leaf microbiota appears to
be a derived form of the root Miqo'te we
think really the major inoculum source
for leaf associated bacteria are derived
from root associate bacterium from soil
bacteria and this is based on an
extensive species intersection which
in the leaf and the root micro voters
using this culture independent community
profiling and I think there's also now
support on the basis of whole genome
drafts more than for nerd isolates that
revealed this large overlap of genome
encoded functional capabilities but also
significant differences at the level of
individual functional categories and I
think this is now most strongly
supported by our microbiota
reconstitution experiments showing that
leaf and root rot symptoms colonize
cognate host organs and are capable of
ectopic Legion enroute colonization and
I think this really raises the
possibility that bacteria from roots
make it up to above-ground parts and
vice versa so I think there's an
unexpected dynamic between the leaf and
the microbiota and I think some evidence
I don't have time to go into details
we've also now strong evidence for
microbiota specialization to their
respective leech alright
so I thought that in the next five or
ten minutes I'd tell you a little bit
more how we now take advantage of our
culture collections of the root microbe
order to test proposed functions of the
microbiota and one of the proposed
functions from an early time point was
really indirect pathogen protection so
this is now again a bottom-up approach
where we use this reconstitution
experiments to test this this function
and for this purpose I need to introduce
to you foods arrium oxes form i'm sure
many of you will be aware of this fungal
pathogen of arab adaxes that severely
inhibit the arab adopts is gross so if
you grow arab adopts is just xle on on
agar plates this is how it looks like
you know for yeah germ-free plants but
if you add foods arrium oxes form the
plants really grow very poorly and one
can actually visualize growth of this
food arrium fungus by lectin staining
for some of this form is a soil borne
vascular pathogen these are the fungal
hyphae that surround the arab adopts
attitudes and the fungus also makes it
into the vasculature and really this
this results in this severe
disease symptoms and what we were
wondering is and these are experiments
from young by and K aroma what would
happen if we Col inoculate our roots
with foods area maps of Spore impose an
individual root microbiota from our
culture collection and and this shows
the difference so the the presence of
this be one bacterium class for our
boxes form essentially rescues and
adopts us grows and we can see also some
rescue in the presence of this bacterium
but this the term has no antifungal
activity and this correlates indeed if
you look microscopically the the foods
are iam - in the presence of these
bacteria highly distorted and in in in
almost all cases the fungus cannot any
longer enter the vasculature roots so of
course we had to do this more
systematically and young and in case
they tested about fifty of our Reiser
bacterial strains and we quantified the
protective activity of these bacteria
against Fusaro infection by measuring
shoot fresh wait and so these are the
controls this is if you incubate Arab
topsis plants with Rosario Malone the
plants essentially die and if you grow
them axenic Lee this is this is a shoot
fresh wait and then this is the shoot
fresh weight in these ternary
interactions so the host the bacterium
and the fungus and we see a range of
infection phenotypes we can broadly
define three categories one categories
these rise of bacteria where there's
unrestricted force RM - gross there's
intermediate growth and then these
Victor I really strongly protect Arab
adopts us against rosarium and if you
overlay on these results those bacteria
that are highly route in which you will
note that in this class we find almost
only bacteria there are highly route
enriched
members of the micro
and they are taxonomically quite diverse
bacteria so one of our hypothesis on the
basis of this result was that evolution
selection might have favored rude
microbiota members with strong
protective activity against soil borne
pathogenic fungi so Stefan haka a
postdoc in the lab he decided to test
this hypothesis by expending our work
from Rosario Marxist forum to another
soil borne really an economically
relevant pathogen vetted ceiling Dali
and practice relic marina and another
root infecting collector trichome
pathogen collector trichome in kaanum
but but he decided he knew rather than
using this time-consuming and and really
complex experiment with a fungus the
host and the bacterium just to test
binary interactions so just Co incubate
the fungal pathogens and the individual
rise of bacteria from our culture
collection so these are he tested a
total of 90 of them and then he
developed a quantitative readout to
measure fungal growth in these Co
cultures so this is all done in 96
microtiter plates and the results of
these testing the interactions of these
rise of bacteria individual rise of
bacteria with these four different fungi
the results are shown in from triplicate
experiments for each of the four fungi
and they are visualized by a heat map
where the cool blue colors indicate
fungal growth inhibition and the red
colors indicate growth promotion and I
hope you agree with me what we could see
is that their individual file o genetic
lineages of the root microbiota that
prefer that confer strong protective
activity against all of these four fungi
for example these apple bhakta than the
true Ramona's here and the messer eyes
open Rhizobium and there are other ones
the streptomyces they're very potent
against forum access forum but their
activity against practice for at Koch
arena is lousy and so based on these
results and when we compare the results
from these binary
interaction screen with these try
trophic interactions
system you will note that there's clear
overlap between the results so what we
conclude
from these experiments is that specific
taxonomic lineages of the bacterial
microbots of direct inhibitory activity
you don't necessarily need the host
that's very important and against a wide
range of soil borne pathogenic root
colonizing fungi so what we infer from
these experiments that indirect
protection against soil borne fungal
pathogen is a major physiological
function of the Arab topsis Bitterroot
microbiota
so essentially it looks it it looks you
know as if Arab adopts is really
recruits a subset of the soil bacteria
right and and that many of these route
associated and route and which bacteria
help the plant to protect itself against
attack from these soil borne fungal
pathogens now you could still criticize
us and you could say well you know this
is you've just tested one fungus one
bacterium and one house it's still not
in the community context so this is
really now I think going in the right
direction and where we've now tested
this is in the calcite clay system if
you just focus on this one
these are germ-free plants this is when
we add 30 of our bacteria rise of
bacteria that we've tested also in the
in the binary or the Tri trophic
interactions system the plants still
grow happily but this is if we really
incubate the plants with our deadly mix
of for soil borne fungal pathogens and
the plants essentially die and if you
add then the frontal community and the
30 microbiota members using this rescue
so I think this suggests really that the
protection against these soul borne
pathogen also can be reproduced under
laboratory conditions in the community
context all right so I think do I still
have yes I think I still have 10 minutes
or so and because I promised that during
the last part of my presentation and
also because Maria is in there in the
audience I mentioned in my introduction
that the route that the plant microbe
order does not involve only bacteria but
they are also association between
healthy plants
and sunshine and this illustrates the
beautiful biodiversity of fungi route
associated fungi that we've isolated
from our topsis roots and so these are
all fungal endophyte that we've isolated
from surface sterilized Arab lobsters
roots grown in natural soil now one
difficulty with the fungal endophyte or
with a fungal microbiota if you like is
that plant associated fungi are hyper
diverse in natural plant populations so
this is fundamentally different from the
Bitterroot microwatt I recall you know I
mentioned to you there is a highly
reproducible taxonomic structure
consisting with this proteobacteria
actinobacteria and so on but for fungi
you know this is terrible you know you
just isolate too many and and that makes
it difficult to discriminate between
stochastic encounters and associations
that have equal physiological relevance
that's really that's a challenge and one
way to overcome that limitation is that
you sample over successive years and
this illustrates you how we've done it
and I want to discuss with you this is
worth there's no in revision yeah how we
do those those experiments so we
isolated this fungus which is called
color to try come topiary from healthy
asymptomatic plants in natural herb
adaxes
populations of the central plateau of
Spain and and you can see these are four
different populations and it's really an
endemic fungus in the central plateau of
Spain we examined habitats from Germany
and France and we could not detect this
ones but here you've it's really it's
persistent over consecutive years there
was one other reason why this fungus
attracted us and I think the the
pathologist's you know may know this
because I'm almost all characterized
call it to trichrome fungal species
cause plant diseases you know
this is toffee earlier these are some of
its cousins and they cause diseases on
fruits and leaves and roots so so why
why is this funk
is it capable to engage in association
with healthy asymptomatic plants so that
was something that we wanted to
understand in greater detail and one
important clue really came from a closer
look at the natural habitats where you
find this fungus so they died I don't
know whether any one of you have ever
had the chance to visit the central
plateau of Spain this is really a harsh
environment and the soil is very low in
nutrients in particular it's it's no in
phosphate and so these poor Arab
adopters plants they really have a hard
time to survive in these arid OPS's
populations so um what we thought is to
better characterize sorry I need to go
back to better characterize the system
that we again apply our reductionist
approach that I explained to you before
with aperture micro motor with this
plant fungus interaction and so we
generated a transgenic GFP expressing
collector fragment of the area we
inoculated with the germ free arrow
drops as Francis and erupts as plants
expressing a plasma membrane marker
protein and we noticed this is fungus
really forms dense extra reticle -
surrounding area but opposite roots but
if you take a cross-section through a
root this is really remarkable you know
the fungus ramifies within the root
tissue it's you know these are all
fungible hydrate you find them between
our bird OPS's root cells but also
inside root cells is really expensive
colonization and without causing visible
symptoms so in the lab the plants stay
healthy so um because of this habitat
features and the low nutrient conditions
we wondered you know what will happen if
we grow our bird OPS's under defined
nutrient limiting conditions and we
tested phosphate nitrate and this is the
typical
7no these are four week old Arab adopts
as plants grown under low phosphate
conditions 50 50 micromolar at this
condition our bird OPS's initiates the
phosphate starvation response the roots
are stunted and there's reduced
shoot biomass and this is what happens
when you add this color to try to
interfere they roots are elongated and
there's
Creason shoot biomass we can quantify
the shoot fresh wait this is the Mach
control this is if you add the toffee
and a fungus so there's a growth
promotion activity this is an important
control he'd killed fungus and this is
another important control when we add
the cousin of profile D which is the
pathogenic in kaanum root colonizing
economy fungus and there's a of course a
reduction in in biomass in importantly
and the high phosphate levels are
sufficient phosphate level if you add
the fungus there's no increase in shoot
biomass but it's not only that Arab
adopts Asst grew that this fungus
promotes Arabidopsis growth under low
phosphate but it also increases the
fertility so the reproductive fitness of
the plant and you can measure that
simply by counting the number of fruits
of Arab adoption and there's very clear
there's an increase in the fruit level
so how how does this fungus promote
paradoxus growth under phosphate
limiting conditions and this is how we
took advantage of the tools that have
been developed by the micro riser
community and the way how we conduct
these experiments we grow our adopts us
plants on these large agar plates and
inside the agar plates we we place a
small petri dish and in the small petri
dish we add the fungal spores and we add
a p33
so auto phosphate radioactively-labeled
order for trade and then what happens is
the fungus growth you know outside of
this inner compartment establishes
connectivities with the roots and then
we measure radioactivity in the shoots
after three weeks of ko incubation and
the results that kill Becquerel you know
program dry weight in individual plants
is shown in this plot and i hope you
agree with me that there is really a
remarkable amount of phosphate that is
transferred from the fungus via the -
via the roots to the chute and
importantly if we now use the pathogenic
cousin of colletotrichum topiary
there is you know very minor transfer
and what i find even more remarkable
under high phosphate conditions so
phosphate sufficient amounts then this
benefit
on this trophy Eric cannot transfer any
longer phosphate to the shoes so what
this tells us is that the transfer of
phosphate is strictly regulated on
phosphate availability in the medium so
we wondered of course what is the
genetic control of this and I mentioned
before that Arab adopts is in all plants
have developed as a complex genetic
system to monitor phosphate availability
and then to adjust growth in response to
phosphate starvation that's the
phosphate starvation response system and
so we wondered you know whether this
growth promotion that we see in wild
type plants whether that is dependent on
these genetic components and this shows
you one results this is the pH f1 gene
that is actually necessary to release
phosphate transporters from the ER to
the plasma membrane and if you look into
that mutant you know clearly the plant
growth promotion is impaired and what I
find more interestingly if you now
measure fungal biomass in this mutant
only under low phosphate conditions then
you see excessive growth so then this
very sophisticated beneficial
interaction is is impaired alright so
then in the next step we were interested
in examining at the transcriptome level
changes transcriptional reprogramming
induced by the fungus and so for this
purpose we've carried out time-resolved
rna-seq experiments and we noted that in
Arab Dobson roots there's a large number
of genes that are differentially
regulated these are 16 pairwise
comparisons very complex data set but I
want to pay your attention just to this
cluster of genes cluster 9 genes that
are specifically up regulated in the
presence of sufficient amounts of
phosphate and in the presence of the
beneficial fungus but they are not
approved in the presence of the fungus
and phosphate deficient conditions and
if you look you know what do these genes
encode they are strongly enriched in
genes that are involved in innate immune
responses so it looks as if our bird
OPS's activates defense gene expression
and innate immune responses to the
fungus specifically only in the presence
of sufficient phosphate but not under
phosphate deficiency and there was one
cluster of genes from these cluster mine
genes that attracted it specifically
because these are genes that encode for
indole and tryptophan metabolic
processes and there's a particular
reason for this because several years
ago we had shown that this class of
compounds and and these genes encode in
DeLuca simulates a class of secondary
metabolites in Arabidopsis that these
confer potent immune responses to fungal
pathogens so we wondered what will
happen if we deplete arable OPS's plants
of the biosynthesis of these secondary
metabolites and you can do that in
arabic OPS's by using a double mutant of
these p450 genes and the result is shown
here so these plants in the absence of
the pathogens they just grow like wild
type plants that there's no effect but
then if you add the beneficial fungus it
kills the host so now in the absence of
these compounds the beneficial call it a
try to interfere the fungus becomes a
pathogen so I think what this tells us
is that these secondary metabolites that
have been proposed to have antibiotic
functions again pathogens that they may
have novel functions and they they
clearly are necessary for the
establishment of an interaction with the
beneficial route associated from this
and I think that's somewhat
thought-provoking so end of data slides
I think I'd like to zoom out and just
like to put this work a little bit into
a broader context so I think what this
slide really shows is the increase of
what fertiliser consumption and I showed
you that this beneficial fungus really
provides phosphate to its host and helps
the plant to mobilize phosphate from
soil and it's also clear that phosphate
is just one of the three nutrients that
we use in synthetic fertilizers next to
nitrate and to potassium and it's it's
also clear that these
synthetic fertilizers help to feed the
world roughly 50% of the plant
productivity is due to the use of
fertilisers and 50% is plant genetics
but you I guess you will also agree with
me that the excessive use of fertilizers
has detrimental effects on the
environment and in in addition in a
global sources for phosphate in
fertilizers are limited and this
certainly fuels interests in isolating
novel by authorized microbes from from
the plant microbe Alta so but leaving
apart this translational aspect I hope
I've been able to convince you that
really what plant microbe author
research is about it's about studying
interactions between soil microbial
communities in plant genotype and I
think this offers unique possibility
creates new interfaces between
disciplines of right of science that are
traditionally more separated you know
terrestrial microbiology plant science
geochemistry and soil science so I think
this is really where we operate and
where I would like to to extend our work
over the next 5-10 well let's see how
long but yeah ok so I've come to the
conclusion most important slide is
really to acknowledge a fantastic
underground group I think I've mentioned
most of them in passing I should perhaps
really give credit to the computational
scientists Ruben Garrido or Gary
shrinivas and of course out to our
collaborate on the leaf microbiota
Daniel Miller and Julia forth from the
ETH series and a number of funding
agencies and then we have a number of
other external collaborators Alice
McCarty Julia for Holt I mentioned
before Jeff Bengal of course him you
know rather Troy and Konya Petersen so
thanks very much for your
hmm well in the in the manuscript of
course we shied away from any
mechanistic interpretation but actually
if you if you look into the literature
Frank des Eaux actually in the US has
done experiments with gfp-tagged
Rhizobium where he had shown inoculated
them to rice roots and he had shown that
these rhizobia then over time can be
recovered from above-ground paths again
how they get there whether they you know
whether they make it by the
transpiration stream or outside you know
on the root surface on the root surface
that is entirely unclear but I think the
other way so from leaves back to roots I
think this happens well more or less on
a daily basis because every rain shower
you know will wash off leave associated
bacteria then so it's definitely
possible that leaf associate Victor
makes it into the soil and then
recolonize this root so this is I think
really a connected system of leaf and
root Associated bacteria no no no now
actually in this in this closed
compartment system in the case on clay
we water them initially and we make sure
we water them at maximum water retention
capacity and then we have to reward them
once so we open the magenta boxes under
clean bench and then carefully add to
our water just to avoid any perturbation
yeah but it's a it's a good point yes
when you're counseling play
we haven't done those experiments we
because we always feel that it is
important to do experiments in a whole
organism context but I think somewhat
similar experiments have been done by no
ephyra here in the US and he used he
implanted organic carbon sources into
unplanted soil and it's it's very clear
that organic carbon is the most
important trait limiting step for growth
of soil borne bacteria so an unplanted
soil organic carbon is always read
limiting and so I think one of our
hypotheses indeed is that this whole
process of community establishment is
initiated by organic carbons that are
released by root X addition and that
serves you know initiates a substrate
driven community establishment process
but this is you know hand waving at the
moment but I think it becomes
experimentally tractable this piece
yeah I think these are really important
questions actually it's I showed only a
small part of the data and maybe maybe
yes so for example you know this is it
becomes a pathogen if we deplete all of
these branch pathways we've of course
also genetically depleted this branch
pathway the pen to mutant and then you
specifically impair the plant growth
promotion but the plant is still doing
well so one hypothesis is that actually
these metabolic products may have yeah
even a signaling role in growth
promotion that's one possibility
we know when we deplete collects in
production there is no effect whatsoever
so maybe one interpretation is that
these secondary metabolites constrain
the growth or limit the growth of the
fungus to a certain extent and then if
you deplete them then the the farm
there's excessive growth and that's
consistent with the fact that at least
in the sub 79 b-two b-three mutant you
know there's I think six or seven fold
increased fungal biomass compared to
water plants so it looks as if the
fungal colonization is uncontrolled in
the absence of these secondary
metabolites yes yes because what we've
used we've used reporter line for plasma
membrane marker protein or chlorine and
so we can clearly see that the hyphy
that grow inside root cells are
surrounded by a plasma membrane we're
quite confident about that
no not yet no not yet yeah we're testing
of course many many more mutants in this
pathway yeah no I think there's much
more that can be tested I agree
well um I haven't done those experiments
that we've taken indeed we've taken
cross section to different regions of
the route and we see colonization really
from from almost from the root tip to
highly differentiated roots including
secondary growth so I think there's no
we cannot really pinpoint at the moment
a particular developmental stage of the
route where this fungus would establish
these associations I think this is
actually a disadvantage of the system
you know then it's unlike in micro
Reiser where you have these beautifully
a bicycles you know this is really
yeah the fungus is is rehme fiying
throughout the root cortex and
occasionally even makes it into a center
into the central cylinder but that is
really only on rare occasions but it's
mainly found in the in the root cortex
oh yes
so this is very important so we thought
if this were true it's too bad I don't
have the slide with me so we tested our
topsis relatives and for example cad
amina yosuta which is a relative of Tali
Anna but Kadam Anejo suta is naturally
lacks the capacity for camel axon
production and I mentioned before that
if we genetically impair camel axon
production Arabidopsis we see retained
growth promotion and so in Kedah
maninsuit a-- also this fungus
colonizers adopts us and promotes growth
but when we tested capsular rubella
capsule a rubella is one of the very few
grass
Casey that has lost the capacity for
endo glucosinolate production then
capsule Arabella looks like a sip 1700
to v3 double milk so it kills capsule ah
and this is relevant because in Spain
capsule a rubella and that air adopts
italiana share the same habitat so I
think one of our hypothesis is that
these secondary metabolites are actually
a host range determinant so yeah at
least let's what the data tell us so far
yes yes now I think this is one of the
central questions you know how to what's
a minimum complexity community what
determines the taxonomic structure this
highly reproducible taxonomic structure
of the community and and of course now
having access to this culture collection
enables us to test this you're
absolutely right you know if you have
206 root Drive bacteria the number of
combinations you can test is beyond
possibility so you need to have some
strategic plan one possibility is you
can deplete particular taxonomic
lineages let's say you take away the
proteobacteria another one is you can
take away the bacteria it is that there
will be one way another possibility is
it's realistic you can test in binary
interactions interactions between the
bacteria themselves so that is possible
and this is one route that that we are
pursuing because we believe that
antagonistic interactions so bacteria
bacteria interactions are very important
for microbiota establishment but that's
these are ongoing so it was very
important Explorer yeah we do
experimental evolution in the lab now so
we use our culture collection and then
we apply a define nutrient stress for
example low phosphate and then we
incubate them with the bacteria then we
isolate the synthetic community and then
we relocate for a second time and we are
now I think generate
six or generation seven on the host side
and in the back you love course these
are thousands and thousands of virtual
generations and so this is really I
don't know whether this will work but
that's one idea that you can apply
experimental evolution strategies and
you can test whether there's real time
evolution to support plant growth but
that's yeah that's something for the
future yes that's another I think this
is you know this is why you know we tend
to say in Cologne you know we are facing
the candy shop problem you know more or
less you can start so many things now
that it's and if you start too many
things you can feel really bad so I
think one needs to prioritize very very
carefully so remind me again that yes
yes yes yes absolutely
so this is something that we are now
that's a project that we've started
actually in a collaboration with
Schengen here not far from here Michigan
we now we do bar coding of our bacterial
culture collection with a tn7
you know you can you can barcode them
and then we can add because the
fundamental question about resilience of
the community is so if you I think the
major function of a community is that
it's more than the sum of the parts
so there are emergent properties that
you cannot explain in on the basis of
the individuals and I think a very
popular theory in ecology is that a
community whatever community of organism
is resistant to invasion of alien
members so what we do now with our
bar-coded
route drive bacteria that we add them to
a preformed root microbiota of plants
grown in different soil types and then
we can test their invasion and
persistence so I think this is one way
we know this is a very rare event that
really a bacterium can intrude can make
it you know into a preformed community
the molecular basis of this I think that
is again it's years of research ahead
but it's it's certainly something that
is of fundamental importance to
understand in its I think it's in part
it's already you know during
establishment of these virtual
communities that yeah these bacteria
must be competitive
they must out-compete all of their
competitors that are in the in the soil
zillions and zillions of bacteria so
they they must have a very high
competitiveness yes yes oh yeah these
are again very important questions so of
course now we have as I try to explain
our core culture collections and we have
the whole genome sequences one way to
infer functions of the microbiota is you
use meta genomic approaches but a major
limitation of meta genomic approaches is
that only 20% of the sequences could
actually be annotated now when we use
our whole genome sequences it looks like
as if you know the the number of genes
that we can annotate on the basis of
meta-genome approaches is really
dramatically increases so I think I hope
that with the whole genome sequences
that our future meta-genome approaches
will become more meaningful that's one
thing but I also believe that at least
one hypothesis is that the adaptation or
the the functional adaptation is not in
the core genome but it's in the
accessory on the pan genome of of these
virtual communities and this may explain
why we have this highly reproducible
taxonomic structure and irrespective of
whether we grow you know plants you know
in the US or in Europe or in Asia or
whatsoever we always end up with the
same taxonomic structure but of course
looking at the whole genome level there
may be signals of biogeography and there
may be adaptations to particular
environments that's that's my hypothesis
yeah and so again it's it's it's a
long-term question that I think through
increased availability of whole genome
sequences and hopefully many many more
systematic culture collections we can
address this systematically production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu